on célèbre un anniversaire aujourd'hui
sa lèvre un anniversaire qui le sait qui
sait quel anniversaire nous célébrons je
vais donner la parole à maxime denis à
cela nous sommes changé c'est la même
volonté la voix nikos dans c'était votre
voix données dont c'est l'anniversaire
de la star academy date il suffit qu'on
arrête nikos est conçu tu nous regardes
pour les désoler nikos je pensais que
j'avais un petit don don alors ça fait
18 ans et c'est déjà un vrai un vrai
événement à l'époque la première
téléréalité musicale et la saison une
avait quand même 30 millions d'euros de
budget on voit plus sa vision à 130
millions d'euros de budget ils sont deux
saisons 2007 wiki six mois je me
souviens effectivement j'étais allé sur
le plateau de la star academy et c'était
vraiment le plus grand plateau d'europe
c'était bluffant on n'avait jamais vu ça
les lumières gratton c'était vraiment
extraordinaire
l'on rappelle c'était le 4 septembre
2001 l'émission très vite devenu un
événement énorme succès avec plus de 11
millions de téléspectateurs parfois je
m'appelle pour la demi finale avec jean
pascal et grigny flins va revoir le
lancement de la toute première saison
avec un nikos qui avait 18 ans de moins
qu'un regard des trente ans bonsoir
soyez les bienvenus en direct sur tf1
nous sommes le samedi 20 octobre
il est exactement 21 53 vous avez
entendu parler ces derniers temps de
star académie aujourd'hui c'est le grand
soir
bienvenue soyez les bienvenus à star
académie que va-t-il se passer
il avait trente 30 ans ni taux je sais
que le lancement de la star ac a été une
catastrophe industrielle catastrophe
totale et qu' il était à une semaine de
l'arrêt de l'émission ils ont eu droit à
une semaine de plus
parce qu'il savait pas il ya eu pas y
avait une semaine c'était compliqué
c'est un budget énorme il va contrer des
neiges étaient signées est la suite du
carton du loft sur m6 et donc il y avait
eu un transfert de deux programmes et
ils ont donné une semaine et la semaine
d'après il y avait du rugby et grâce à
cette concurrence plus faibles et
comment a commencé à monter ils ont
maintenu et c'était et c'était peut-être
la vie qui avait été approchée pour
présenter les projets pour les kabyles
se poser la question de savoir si t'es
un homme qui allait animer ou une femme
l'étude marketing vous avez fait des
études marketing et à l'époque on disait
qu'une femme pouvait pas tenir
éventuellement un prime aussi importants
progrès qui auriez été fabuleuse ouais
ça si besoin alors invité n'dri comme à
fiat mais je fonds north équipe et
violée oui monsieur mais ça fait souvent
des cas le choc le petit casta il était
8e ou 9e sur love story de gens qui ont
refusé de nommer tout le monde avait
refusé sa bastille et tout le monde aura
refusé d'être alors storico vous avez
refusé vraiment abb pécule de 3 c en
mixant de voix sabatier j'ai vu qu'il y
avait dans la liste les gens qu'il était
9e temps et moi quand on m'a appelé pape
alors j'étais d'hésiter déjà en train de
divorcer donc écoutez bien et c'est
amusant parce que moi à l'époque je me
disais bon faut que je travaille j'ai
une famille à nourrir eu des bons je
vais accepter ce qui me propose je ne
savais pas du tout ce que j'allais faire
pas du tout comme ça comme une émission
sociétal mois big brother j'avais je
connaissais pas les brothers et donc
j'ai accepté et vous avez dit oui tout
de suite où vous et tous mérité je vais
célébrité avec stéphane bern
moi j'avais d'écouté je veux bien faire
votre truc là qui arrivent là le loft
mais surtout je veux un bon contrat pour
la rentrée un bar à lait
et donc je vais un bon contrat avec des
programmes prévus pour la rentrée et
j'ai fait le loft où les moquettes aussi
voulait un garçon absolument et garçons
à la présentation et au coeur d'amour
quoi ok mais je sais ce que tu seras
dire les 10 gagnants d'astarac les yeux
fermés ou là et je fermais am elle fut
la bête en référé 11 à l'énergie doe sur
laurier saint symphorien renard y est ça
le rôle et l'oreillette barça d'ailleurs
je n'ai pas besoin de lui parce que j'en
ai rien à carrer non je n'y a pas
d'enjeu il emmerde voilà vous pouvez me
citer le ballon je lui ai rejoint
l'équipe ira loin
elodie frégé macheda goerig marshall
magalie vaé saison 5
oui et à partir d'assister qu'avant sa
mère ici québec à vélo rose bonbon très
bien cyril cinélu des cafés il ya
quentin mosimann à grégory lemarchal on
l'a déjà dit vous avez donc elodie frégé
a gagné et qui a partagé avec michel on
avait volé l'orangé
[Rires]
c'est pas moi je voulais j'ai pas volé
leur âge ils n'ont fait une histoire
cet orage
on en a marre et qui est sur nrj 12 on
sait plus et fut pourtant il a animé
l'émission il sait même plus quelle
vérité il ya même pas une disque
derrière non away and en quoi sur nrj 12
il ya un peu de disques hariri arrivé à
voir un 10 qui devait gagner se sont pas
entendus et la maison de disques elle
gagne en est le producteur a mentionné
la pop il s'est barré c'est lauren cas
d'ali baba la lorraine a mis hors de moi
son père ralph jamais faire c'est un
rendez vous télévisuel très important et
on le sait vous impliquez on en parle à
la machine à café tout ça mais quand on
voit ça très france 3 limousin mais
c'est vrai alors elles ont quand même
envie y voir quand j'ai vu l'entrée de
nikos faire j'ai cru que présentait le
soir trois finales et dès qu un baril à
d'incroyables c'est un business en panne
ou à leurs copines en ces mois alors
quand on voit un film qui à 18 ans ça
peut être un chef-d'oeuvre mais que fait
donc la différence entre l'art et la
télévision
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai vraiment
nos jours de voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ga
[Applaudissements]
mais
alors que les chiffres sont justes et de
julien johnny hallyday lorsqu'il est
parent doit être parent se présenter
deux fois et chantait une chanson il a
pris 1 millions d'euros quoi par
anastasia les chiffres sont vrais et il
était produit par le camus et l'année
d'après c'est michel sardou qui est
parent qui chante et qui lui est payé
500 mille euros produit par camus aussi
non sardou l'apprend apprend que johnny
après cinq cent mille de plus celle
d'avant l'engueulade commence entre les
deux et de la haine est aussi une
engueulade camus c'est pour ça que camus
écrit la peste euros je comprends
maintenant je comprends le sublimant
très bonnes infos mais avons vaincu
c'est fou juste à 100% mais déjà frère n
1 500 millions de chansons sans rigoler
c'était l'époque je mets les gens qu'ils
avaient pas besoin
la première à la dernière et jean une
chanson avec un élève fait oublier qu'à
l'époque avait destin international qui
venait sur les plateaux télé qui sait
pas quelle tenue à vous tous ri quand
ils ont vu les audiences pas au début on
dit je viendrai pas on se sert ni
parvenir nous ici bah oui c'est dans les
covenants ici tout quand vos débuts vous
voulez pas dire que vous avez vu le cac
gagne et on veut pas du tout
[Rires]